this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists today
we're going to talk about the high price
of materialism you know ryan this friday
is
black friday it is
yes i mean when this episode comes out
yes okay
i mean i guess with the right attitude
any friday can be black friday well i
think some
what's fascinating is it is changing
this year because everything has changed
been turned upside down
if there's one one good thing to to come
out of this whole
pandemic i thought it was going to be
everyone became united all of a sudden
that didn't happen but some people did
and we talked to rob bell about that a
few months ago
but i think that you know one thing that
we're noticing is
a lot of retail stores are closing on
thanksgiving day
um we're probably not going to see wild
doorbuster sales
i would imagine not i mean there may be
some places that do this that are
trying to be counter cultural or or
whatever um
which would be weird because consumerism
is not counter-cultural
it is the culture really all right about
it we're in a
consumer culture yeah a materialist
culture you know in our first film
minimalism
juliette shore talked about maybe the
problem is actually we're not
materialist
enough yeah like we we don't value the
the right things
because we opt instead for just any
thing
yeah ooh you could tweet that podcast
sean yeah i love the uh
i love how she talks about materialism
because every time i hear that it
sounds like a pejorative to me but
because we don't care about our stuff
we're actually not very materialistic
right and when we treat everything as
disposable now don't get me wrong i'm
not saying cling on to everything
no what i'm saying is get rid of the
excess and that's what this whole
minimalist message
is about but then when we're we're
bringing things in we're doing so in a
sort of
uh you i heard this term recently i
think it's a word that's been it's
coming to vogue recently
we're creatives right but i heard this
term curatives
and i think as as minimalists often
that's what we are we are curatives we
want to
we don't want to shun stuff we want to
shun the inappropriate stuff
yeah and what is appropriate for you may
not be appropriate for me and
vice versa i've got this book here ryan
i wanted to read an excerpt to start the
podcast today this is called the high
price of materialism
it's by professor tim casser and this is
the intro to the book we're going to
dive more into this later during the
maximal episode i've got some great
stuff to cover with you but i just
wanted to kick off this conversation
before we get into our audience
questions
with this excerpt cool the first chapter
is called mixed messages
there's a quote at the beginning it's
six lines chase after money and security
and your heart will never unclench care
about people's approval
and you will be their prisoner
do your work then step back the only
path to serenity
five century ago the chinese philosopher
lao zhu pinned these six lines
warning people of the dangers of
materialistic values
that's 2500 years ago unbelievable yeah
and we're still
tackling it today in fact um that's what
this book goes into
sages from almost every religious uh and
philosophical background have similarly
insisted that focusing on attaining
material possessions and social renown
detracts from what is meaningful about
life although although we may not nod
our head
although we may nod our heads in
recognition of this ancient wisdom
such advice is largely drowned out by
today's consumeristic hubbub of messages
proclaiming that
material pursuits accumulation of things
and the presentation of
quote the right image
provide real worth deep satisfactions
and a genuinely meaningful life
newspaper headlines exalt the local
lottery winner
get rich quick books climb to the top of
best seller lists
multi-color ads flash on web pages
celebrities on television hawk
everything from sport utility vehicles
to
mascara although they differ in form
each of these messages essentially
proclaims
that happiness can be found at the mall
on the internet
or in the catalog both types of messages
about the value of materialism coexist
in contemporary life and they can be
difficult to know whether to follow the
sages
or the celebrities who is right will the
pursuit of money and possessions
bring about the good life or the
promises
of consumer society false
i mean obviously i think people know
where we stand on
this continuum yeah but at the same time
we're not professing to be people who
live without or deprive ourselves in
perpetuity yeah you know it's funny and
the new documentary we have coming out
there's like a scene of me in my
apartment you know like this is now
yeah thank you is it
uh yeah uh in our documentary less is
now that will be coming out
soon-ish january 1st there is
a scene in the beginning of me and my
apartment trying to get back on track
here
uh where it shows like my tv
and like some books and stuff and i was
like oh man like i'm gonna get
criticized for like
oh you have a tv and you have books and
i almost asked matt to cut out the tv
but i'm like no dude yeah like i want
people to realize
that this isn't an extreme lifestyle
we're not trying to make people feel bad
for the things that they have we just we
want them to feel good we want them to
be
materialistic in the true sense right um
i hope people who don't have a tv i hope
they don't see that and then go out and
buy a tv because i have one
but but yeah no it's just interesting
because you're absolutely right like
we're not trying to
we're not trying to be aesthetics we're
not trying to show people that
hey look you can live with as little as
possible like that's not the message
right i do want you to be unhappy if you
are unhappy meaning i want you to
recognize that you're unhappy or
discontented by the status quo that
you've created
and what i mean by that is if you've
reached a point where there is
dissatisfaction in your life don't cover
it up with more stuff
right acknowledge the fact and sit with
that for a moment and say wow
yeah i've done some things you know you
and i especially in our late 20s we
reached this this tipping point by the
time we were 30 years old where it was
like
wow we've we've pursued this path the
of materialism of all of the the
supposedly nice things that are going to
make us as
as professor kessler says here he said
um
happiness can be found at the mall on
the internet or in the catalog
at least that was my hypothesis and yeah
i was proved wrong
now that i will say this you know i'm
not
allergic to money and and i think people
often conflate money and things
i think the pursuit of money alone is
probably not a
a noble or worthwhile goal but i think
we all need some stuff there was a quote
on the second page here from
the uh writer or from the poet robert
graves
he said there was no poetry in money
and when i when i hear something like
that what i what i hear is that like
all of life's beauty all of life's
mystery
all of life's excitement and joy
is captured outside of money however we
do need money to pay our bills to
uh to have a certain amount of security
in our lives
and that's different for each of us and
i know that when i left the corporate
world i made about 90
less that i made in the corporate world
but it was strangely more financially
secure
because for the first time my life i
took control of
the the bills that i had and got rid of
the vast majority of them virtually all
of them
and lived off of 23 000
a year but i not only was i happier
i was i was more secure so money also
doesn't buy you security i found
that money is an amplifier and i don't
think the same thing about material
possessions necessarily
so hear me out uh money if you have
really
bad habits man it's going to take you
down
it's going to accelerate that bad path
really quickly how many lottery winners
have we heard of
that just go off the deep end very
quickly yeah
almost all of them there's some
exceptions there may be someone who has
already good habits and they happen to
win the lottery
and now they're they're set they can
contribute beyond themselves more
because it will amplify those good
habits you're a generous person and all
of a sudden you win the lottery
wow you're probably going to be generous
with that money told you about the
people who won the lottery in lebanon
ohio right now like so my
ex-father-in-law
was president of a bank in lebanon
you'll never guess what bank
anyway uh he told me that during his
presidency
five people won the lottery four of them
went bankrupt
and he said the other one that the other
one that didn't go bankrupt
what they did is they lived their life
like they had never won the lottery
right they didn't change a thing they
had a bunch of money in their bank
account
right and and so they had a bigger
safety net so to speak
right and and i think the opposite is
true with
our possessions whereas if you have good
habits
you don't need more st if the more stuff
you have it can actually get in the way
of those good habits yeah
i think money won't necessarily get in
the way of your good habits
and and i think that's that's the
difference here by the way i don't think
i'm allergic to stuff
either i am i do have this particular
allergy to
excess and and that's what i really want
to talk about today i think some of our
questions are geared
around that but i want to before we get
into those questions ryan there were a
few things that really stood out here
yeah real quick though expound on you
said that money is an amplifier
right but stuff cannot be an amplifier
right
okay so so what i mean by that is is
i think that you so if you're making
really bad habits
if you get more stuff it's just it's a
pacifier it's gonna yeah you'll continue
to make bad
habits but if you are making really good
good decisions you have really good
habits in in your life oh okay
yeah you get a whole bunch of stuff i
see it in the comments it's actually
it's actually probably going to get in
the way of your good habit
i see what you see yeah i understand
that context it's gonna here's a better
way to look at it
our stuff is distracting yeah it's shiny
and yeah the the all of these sort of
analogies of bells and whistles
and and just it's it's everything once
we get everything
we're distracted by everything i
remember when you did your packing party
it was you were finally like your house
was
no longer distracting right now that's
jarring at first when you remove those
pacifiers
those distractions but when you start to
deal with that you realize like
oh i've been filling the void
but if you fill the void with stuff it
only widens
the void you talk about the pursuit of
money
and i totally agree like that there's no
joy there's no poetry in the pursuit of
money
but you know instead of the pursuit of
money maybe people should look at the
pursuit of well-being
and during that pursuit there are things
there
are there are there is money that is
going to
help you on that pursuit sure yeah but
yes they're like you said like they are
they are uh amplifiers or tools we talk
about that a lot too it's it's a tool
rather than
than the then the end game essentially
i've got a few more things
on sort of in that in that vein here
there was a study
done at the montana state university in
bozeman i think it's on page 63 of this
book the montana state university
is this ohio um oh here it is right here
so yeah uh students who strongly focused
on the pursuit of wealth
fame and image reported lower
quality relationships with friends and
lovers
that is materialistic values were
associated with shorter
less positive and more negative
relationships
than non-materialistic values other
studies
find that materialistic individuals
experience more alienation
in their social relationships than
non-materialistic people
and then it goes on to say students
highly focused on financial success
were likely to feel estranged from their
culture
yeah and i think that was maybe one of
the things that happened to those four
lottery winners all of a sudden
they they felt like outsiders right
because everyone starts treating them
differently wanting things from them
etc and or the other side is if
if you're pursuing something the rest of
your culture isn't
uh or the rest of the people around you
aren't pursuing
then it's going to be at odds yeah with
um
with the life that they're living and so
you're going to feel like an
outsider if if you're pursuing that and
then of course what do we do i know i
felt that way in my 20s
so what did i do well i'll just get more
stuff because eventually
or more status right eventually i'll be
like the people i want to be like and
then maybe they'll accept me and i'll
get to be with them but no they were
just as lonely and
as isolated as me it was like it was
like going to
some place in the middle of the ocean
where you have all these tiny little
individual islands like i've got my own
island but
i'm on my own island yeah so i was um
driving down rodeo drive
recently as an anthropology experiment
yeah and you know people wearing masks
outside it's a saturday
and bex and i got out and we just
started walking to to look to see what's
going on
it was really fascinating to me because
there are people
just on saturday morning they
are lined up outside of these really
expensive stores where you can buy
a louis vuitton face mask for twelve
hundred dollars
what can you imagine um
yeah wow talk about virtue signaling
right but i think we all do that i mean
that's an extreme example that's yeah
that's maybe the terminus
yeah but but is it that different from
the nike symbols i've seen on a on a
face mask
it's essentially doing the same thing
it's it's just doing so
amplified right and what we're trying to
because
a swoosh on your face mask or you
on on a piece of clothing even doesn't
improve the piece of clothing in any way
if it did if it made you breathe better
or
jump higher or whatever great
so be it but it doesn't do that what it
does is it signals i'm this type of
person
to to other people but i think what it
actually does
is it gets it it gets people
to advertise on behalf of an of a
corporation for free
in fact not even for free it's you
paying louis vuitton twelve hundred
dollars
for the privilege of advertising their
products their logo and
and so it's it's this very it's the
strange dynamic and i noticed this that
you know there are a lot of people
waiting out there they were mostly
younger
and what this book talks about uh the
high price of materialism
is that you and i grew up really poor
and poor people
tend to make decisions with their money
that are very
sort of immediate not thinking about
the future and i can tell you from from
the first 18 years of my life
those habits were established and i
spent the next 12 years of my life
finally making some money but those
habits continued throughout my my late
teens and all throughout my 20s until i
was about 30.
and and that that way of living as i
even though i was making good money i
had the habits
of my poor young self
let's spin this as soon as we get it
let's live paycheck to paycheck
yeah let's not consider the future or
let's spend it before we get it
yeah why that's a bit worse in fact on
the maximum episode i do want to talk to
you about
the history of consumerism i want to see
is it 2500 years old is it 5 000 years
old or maybe it's about 10 to 12 000
years old
and i've got some some philosophies
around that before we before we get into
these questions though
this book talked about how celebrities
and influencers
are are really part of the problem i was
having a conversation with sheila from
habits of waste
on this podcast and she
talked about how one of the worst things
that's happened to the plastic industry
is
when people like jennifer anderson
started advertising for bottled water
and and we don't realize how you know we
are so triggered but i really like this
person and so i'm going to
now purchase this product they recommend
because it's going to make me similar
to them it's going to make me jennifer
anderson or it's going to make me kylie
jenner
or it's going to make me lebron james or
or whomever
and it's almost as though we need
some actual celebrities to to
to take on a more intentional message of
not consuming
of advertisements suck now i think there
are some that have done it really well
yeah you can't imagine kurt cobain ever
being in a pepsi ad
right or radiohead ever being used in a
gap commercial
right uh and so there are there are some
but
how can they take an active stance uh
against it how do we have
the thing i talked to sheila about is
how do we get brad pitt to
advertise for tap water yeah the tap
water i'm drinking right now because
that's much more powerful than joshua
fields milburn recommending tap water
right but if if he's doing it you're
like well we have to start drinking tap
water it's brad pitt
it's like right now we've got like a 10
to 1 ratio for every 10 celebrities
that are advertising bottled water or
whatever
product you've got one who's trying to
do the right thing so yeah the question
is like how do you reverse
how do you make that a 1 to 10 ratio
what's the upton sinclair quote when he
says you know
you can't change a man's mind when his
income depends on him not changing his
mind right
yeah and i think that's one of the
biggest problems with advertising let's
dive more into that on the maximum we
got some questions here from
michelle in phoenix arizona to start how
do i get started how
do i continue decluttering and cleaning
and
i know that it will make my life happier
but how do i get started my i have three
boys they have tons of legos and toys
and they obviously play with everything
the moment i try to get it out so how do
you
tackle that how do you teach them to
minimize their toys so ryan i think the
easiest thing to do here is if you just
start by getting rid of the three boys i
think the toys go with them
well yeah maybe just try to get rid of
one of them at first
like a minimalism game but with getting
rid of children yeah
that's a horrible man i think you and i
are the only ones who find that funny
yeah you're probably right yeah but no
so here's the thing we don't
want to yeah don't get rid of your kids
the people we love in fact we don't want
to exacerbate or agitate the people we
love i think that is
is a common thing that happens when
couples start decluttering
but only one person is actually doing
the the decluttering
we need to get the buy-in first now
where do you get started
this is a common question why well
because the average american household
the average
western household has hundreds of
thousands of items in it
and we're overwhelmed with stuff we are
already you know michelle is exacerbated
by her stuff
and she's so overwhelmed she doesn't
even know where to start
how do i start simplifying and so we
just throw our hands up
now you and i have done a few different
things in fact we talk about this in
lessons now um where are two different
approaches mine was like i got rid of
one item a day for
30 days just see if i could do it
because anyone can get rid of one thing
a day for 30 days
ultimately that turned into the 30 day
minimalism game which is what i'm going
to recommend
to michelle we have a free minimalism
game calendar on our website
theminimalists.com
game you can download that and it shows
you how many items you're getting rid of
but the way it works is one thing on the
first day two things on
the second day three things in the third
day so by the third day you've gotten
rid of
six things you're getting that momentum
and it's snowballing
it starts off really easy but by mid
month 15 things on day 15 16 day
69 is a day 16 and so forth and so on
and and i think well we've seen that
work for tens of thousands of people
if you want to get a bit more extreme
ryan did a little thing called a packing
party yeah that's uh i don't recommend
that for most people
i mean i'm an extreme person i think
maybe it's because i'm so add
i don't know man like i really need my
attention
powerfully refocused yeah or my
perspective powerfully
refocused and the packing party did that
for me i mean
yeah i packed up everything i packed up
uh
everything literally and i unpacked it
as i needed it
and it was a great experiment i mean
when i was done i had you know 80
of my stuff in boxes and it really
helped me shift my perspective
but you know the minimalism game doesn't
work that's too easy if the packing
party is
too crazy then maybe uh you know
somewhere in the middle you start with
like your powder room or something with
a packing party
yeah um but here you know i had a powder
room
[Laughter]
um i mean if you got powder in there
secondly a powder room
here's here's what i'd recommend for
michelle too uh michelle you've got to
start with your family too
and i don't mean minimize your family
but you got to get them on the same page
so even before you do a packing party
before you do the men's game before you
do the one room packing party unless
it's your own personal room then maybe
you don't have to talk to your kids
about it
but you know what really stands out in
her question to me is how do i get my
kids on board and what you do
is you help them find the benefits
in simplifying so with kids you know
what kids love to do they like to do
a couple things um like it's taken me
everything to not be a smart ass right
now talk about it
right exactly but there are two things
that i know kids like to do one is they
love
to help um that is what i mean i
remember when i was a kid i was always
trying to like pump gas from my dad
i was like always trying to like help my
mom clean the toilets like
and it's funny because i remember my dad
at one point he's like ryan you're gonna
hate pumping gas
just enjoy the time that you don't have
to pump the gap i'm like no but i want
to pump the gas
yeah and uh now i guess i don't hate it
but it's still it's a pain in the ass
but anyway
kids love to help so uh you know
give this as uh to your kids as an
option to help the other thing too
and i guess this kind of goes in line
with helping his kids love
to help others like donate uh
they they'd like to bring others
happiness so if you can help your kids
see
that those those toys that they're
giving up they're being donated to
another kid
and they're making that other kid happy
like the kid is going to love the fact
that they are making someone else happy
so kids love to help they love to assist
and they also like to make other people
happy so find a way to help your kids
see those two things and maybe that'll
just give them a little bit of
of a spark to help you start but
michelle
it's easy to get overwhelmed it's easy
to throw your hands up in the air and be
like i can't do this it's too much my
my kids are in the way and all my other
stuff is in the way like
i get it but you have to start somewhere
and uh
unfortunately there's no magic bullet
answer that we're gonna be able to say
right now to like
help you be like oh yeah i'm gonna
declutter tomorrow and it's all gonna be
done
yeah um the the thing that we're josh
and i are trying to tell you is
start small you gotta start small
yeah and and what i think with the
minimalism game the reason it's going to
work so well for you and your family
is it does help you get some buy-in with
them especially if there's some sort of
outcome you're working towards so i
don't know what the reward is going to
be i don't know what your
your specific kids are into but there
could be a family reward there could be
an individual
reward as well so if you're playing this
game with your entire family
so each person gets rid of one thing on
the first day it all starts out really
easy
and second day you each get rid of two
items whoever goes the longest
wins if you all make it to the end of
the month well you've each gotten rid of
about 500 items
it's a phenomenal start one other thing
for your kids michelle
show them what they're making room for
as they're getting rid of the stuff they
no longer play with
a couple rules there like the 90 90 rule
we call it the seasonality rule
in our minimalist rule book which i'd
love to give you a free copy of
the minimalist rule book you can find it
at theminimalists.com
rulebook and it's a free ebook anyone
can download it
for free or if you want the audiobook
version that is also available ryan and
i record an audio book version but the
rule that stands out in there to me
is the one in 10 out rule yeah because
you're if they get rid of 10 things
maybe they're making room for one new
thing that's
truly going to add value to their life
so i think you'll enjoy that and i think
the rules in there
will help you set up some boundaries
that you need michelle jay
in arlington texas has a question for us
i was wondering about your opinions of
paying for minimalism
that is always having to cough up money
to reduce ad clutter
for example i have to pay to remove ad
clutter from my email reader my podcast
player
and countless other applications and
online tools
are you ever worried that in the future
the only way to escape clutter is to pay
for it
you see no matter what you're paying for
your clutter yeah
whether it's money whether it's time
whether it's attention
you're paying for your clutter yeah so
the question
that jay is asking here is should i pay
money
to not have clutter in my life well the
question is jay is what do you have more
of
money time or attention and which one is
renewable which one isn't
exactly for me it's it's a no-brainer i
pay for
youtube premium it's like 12 bucks a
month and i never
ever see an ad there me too spotify i
pay for the premium
right and and it's because i don't want
to pay with my attention
there it really frustrates me when you
sign up for a service and they still do
advertisements
on the service uh you know the
newspapers are
certainly this way television channel
cable tv has commercials on it but you
pay for i don't have cable tv personally
but like
if you pay for cable tv and then they
also serve up commercials as well
you're paying both and so realize that
the true
cost of these things it's insidious
it's so so much higher than just the
money you pay
now i get it not all of us can afford
to pay for all of these things so
there's a third option
um what is that third option it might
mean
go without yeah it's not like well i
either want the gq
magazine i'll pay for it but then i
don't want any ads or
or you know i'll take the free version
with ads you know that's a probably a
bad example but
uh you can go back to youtube for a
second or isn't hulu
that does commercials doesn't it so
there's like a yeah so there's like a
higher tier version there
yeah well maybe the third option is you
you'd like me you just don't have hulu
right and you use sean's password like i
do
and if you uh sign up for a patreon
we'll give you sean's password right i
was gonna
i was gonna say we have a much better
answer to this uh you'll just have to
pay two dollars to listen to our patreon
episode and we'll give you a much better
answer jay so
no just kidding here here's the thing
jay you're already paying
and that's that this is the danger of
advertising they've tricked you in the
thinking
it's free but if you're not paying for
the product then maybe you are
the product yeah boom tweet that
all right jay enjoy this copy of
everything that remains i'm gonna send
you a copy of that book if you like our
podcast you really like the
audio book version of everything that
remains
it is my favorite book that we've ever
written ryan was just telling me while
we were listening to this question he
has a friend who's on their third time
reading it right now
and um i i get really nice messages
about all the time
it's this narrative this five-year
journey of me and ryan
going through the corporate world
deciding to walk away from that world
and be a lot more intentional with the
fewer
resources that we have it's called
everything that remains
if you want the audiobook we'll send
that to you or the book book or the
ebook we're happy to send those to you
as well jay ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages text your questions and
comments to
area code 937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones and we personally reply to as
many as we
can during the lightning round this is
where ryan and i do our best to answer
every question with a short share but
less than 140 character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place
minimal maxims.com all right
you want to hear from linda let's do it
what's a good way of controlling stuff
you
love but don't really have space for now
this is fascinating i
actually italicized stuff you love i
know that's why i read it like that i
know
and so uh this is we we have a language
problem and i actually want to
argue with ryan about this on the
maximal episode we're running out of
time but
we had a conversation with rob bell a
couple months ago during the maximum he
goes i think this is
where you and i disagree about the the
language problem and i i don't know what
he meant by that so
um we're going to tackle that on the
maximal but i'm going to give you my
pithy answer i was just trying to pick a
fight man well
let's pick one i brought some boxing
gloves and some duct tape
shovel wait a minute it's the only way
you'd be able to beat me up
duct tape by tying my hands behind my
back oh
all right so uh my pithy answer is an
oldie but a goodie love people and use
things because the opposite
never works that's a cheater no yeah
right but why am i saying that here
because
what's a good way of controlling the
stuff you love but don't really have
space for
well stop loving the stuff i mean that's
really the thing
my seven-year-old daughter loves her
stuff she's a child
and the problem is i think we start to
behave like children we get confused and
i think language is really powerful i
know you don't really love
your things the same way that you love
your mother or your children or your
sister
i know that but i think we what happens
we get confused when we start using that
same language
when we say i love you that means
something when i say my iphone is sexy
what a weird thing to say right we're
talking about our technology
excuse me an idea for iphone cases
[Laughter]
there's something there man no we'll
talk about on the maximum
but seriously i i think it's a language
problem so the
what i'm going to start with is let's
start talking about the because
you're saying you love these things but
they're they're getting in
your way you don't enjoy them anymore
well that should be the purpose of the
stuff anyway it should serve a purpose
or bring you
joy and if it's no longer doing that
then
let it go and i think the easiest way to
let it go is if you stop loving it
i don't it's like what if someone gave
like if someone gave me a horse
i love horses it's not a thing though
yeah right but but
i mean even with a horse which isn't a
thing i don't have
the time the attention and the money to
stable a horse
so she might as well be asking me like
hey i don't have the time attention
money to stable a horse how do i do that
right uh if it's causing you discontent
if it's causing you anxiety
then that's a sign that it might be
actually toxic and you may not love it
as much as you think
or even like it as much as you think
that's great so uh
my pithy answer is there is no such
thing
as toxic love
that's solid because here's the thing
you're you're at this point right now
where it is it's gotten to a point where
there's a bit of toxicity there and it
may just be
a micro dose of toxicity but you and i
know that micro dose of toxicity
it's like a little bit of mold right
over after
uh a month a year a decade all of a
sudden
your whole life has taken over and it's
really unhealthy for you yeah
love that pithy answer all right we got
a bunch of listener tips today and some
added value our added value segment
it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week too like
how do i get my wife to get rid of
unused junk that's been sitting in our
basement forever
how do you combat boredom when you get
super minimal
that's my favorite superhero super
minimal super minimal
how do you respond when your boss tells
you to shop for clothes and he
encourages
materialism how do we go about finding
quality items that bring us
value when we're surrounded by a sea of
junk
plus we have questions about clothes
cars appliances the opportunity cost of
materialism
minimalist privilege and a million more
questions
for the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that subscribe to our maximal
episodes on the minimalist private
podcast it's a
completely separate podcast and it's the
most honest way for the minimalist to
earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not a
private podcast supporter you're
literally missing two-thirds
of our show just go and try it out for a
month or three weeks or whatever
it's just two bucks and that's not two
dollars a day you're already spending
two bucks a day on coffee
we're talking two bucks a week it's and
what we do is we try to add much much
much more value than those two dollars
so try it out there's a whole back
catalog of over a hundred
previous private podcast episodes where
we really dive deep with our guests also
individual episodes also we did a bunch
of 50 different quarantine
conversations with with different people
like dave ramsey and
dan savage and and uh glennon doyle
was wonderful so a bunch of people over
there as well you can check it all out
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe you'll get a
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here they are the comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out hey guys it's carly calling from the
gold coast of australia
it was really awesome seeing you on your
tour stop here
one of the callers asked for resources
to do a spirituality
that was a minimalist and i wanted to
recommend the doubted chain
the data chain is an ancient spiritual
text but it's really more of a
philosophy than a religion
there are some people especially in
china though who do follow it
a bit more like a religion but it's
basically an easy read it's just a set
of 81 verses
more like poems and they're about all
different
things but they're all to do with living
a life of meaning and passion
and happiness and there are many many
verses about living
simply and not being materialistic i
don't come across many people who are
actually familiar with this book the
doubt of change
but it's actually the number two most
printed book in all of history
second only to the bible and many
scholars do consider it the wisest book
ever written
so i definitely think anyone that's
interested in a spiritual path
that has something strongly to do with
minimalism it's definitely worth that
worth picking up a copy of the dow to
change
hi josh and ryan i have been a
minimalist since before i even knew
there was such a thing as minimalism
uh but one area that has really suffered
in my minimalism has been
my wardrobe and despised clothes
shopping
i hate looking through racks to find
something that suits my style
i hate piecing together outfits i hate
turning on clothes in the store
and i often go far too long between
shopping sessions because i
hate the entire process the whole
experience
so my small wardrobe suffers but on your
episode about clothing
i think it was ryan who mentioned stitch
fix
so i decided to give them a try i've
received two shipments already and i
absolutely love it i filled out a style
profile online created a pinterest board
and the stylist
nailed it and has me all set up for our
early arizona summers
i now have a wardrobe that looks
intentional makes me feel good about
myself and i didn't hate making it
happen so i want to thank you so
much for the suggestion made my day and
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
well ryan we have we just talked about
it briefly we have our new documentary
coming out on netflix
yeah it's a netflix original this time
yes and it is called
less is now directed by our good friend
matt diabella yeah
and finally like we got to this point
it's funny because we thought like
that's gonna be
four months we'll just knock this thing
out real quick yeah when we started back
in 2017
yes oh man isn't that funny how it's
like so with minimalism we had no
expectation
it was done in like a year and a half
yeah and we were just like blown away
yeah and then yeah this one we were like
oh we'll just recreate that but now we
know what we're doing so it'll be even
shorter
right anyway well it's finally coming
out january 1st
2021 start the new year off with
some simplicity uh the trailer will be
out
in december so you can just stay tuned
to
social media for that we're at the
minimalist on all the platforms
but um yeah this film it's really a deep
dive
into living with less it's has our story
but we also went out and
interviewed about 30 different what
we're calling everyday minimalists
people who were profoundly
affected or influenced by our first film
to let go of
a lot of excess stuff we went into their
homes that's my favorite part of the
documentary i think
yeah it's like it's not just you and i
being like simplify
right you actually get to see and people
get emotional and there's people from
every walk of life uh young old rich
poor it doesn't really matter
every different ethnicity what people
realize is they're
overwhelmed by materialism right and
if you are overwhelmed by materialism
then minimalism might be the solution
to that we also interviewed five
different experts about different areas
like community
and relationships and the economy and
the environment
and families and uh phenomenal
interviews in there and then of course
our story is in there as well
sort of as the thread that weaves this
thing together and it's a relatively
short film it's less than an hour long
we
we wanted to take that minimalism thing
seriously
yeah and so the weird thing is ryan this
is the third time that we've done
this film we have two other versions
that we
we created that we'll never see the
light of day because they weren't right
but it finally came together into this
and for the first time
when i as we went through these
iterations it was getting better and
better
and i remember we got to that fifth cut
of the film when we turned it into
netflix
and i was like oh wow this is even
better
than minimalism and i didn't think i was
ever going to
feel that as we were going through it
because minimalism made me feel
something
so visceral and emotional and finally
matt's a genius obviously we weaved it
together or he weaved it together in
this way where
i don't know it brought out all the
heartstrings to get tugged
yeah he did a great job i can't wait for
it to come out until then uh we have
three seasons of living room
conversations on our youtube channel if
you want to get some answers for your
minimalist questions 60 different
short videos there ryan and i in our
living rooms answering your questions
you can find that at our youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the minimalist it's right there on
the main page just scroll down a bit
living room conversations and you can
just skip around you don't have to watch
any particular order you don't have to
watch all 60 videos
find the ones that resonate with you the
questions that you might be asking
we probably have already answered them
in those living room conversations
on our youtube channel you can follow
the minimalist on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo
to podcast minimalists.com you can
comment on this episode youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at theminimalists.com
you'll also receive our simple sunday
emails and if you leave here today with
just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it bye